Now let's talk about decidability.
I'd like you to tell me which of the following statements are actually decidable
and check whichever ones are.
The first one is given a program P and an input I,
P produces I as its output.
The second statement is given two programs, they will always produce the same output
for a given input.
The third is given a program P and input I, P uses at most 50KB of memory.
Next, given a program P that takes 2 arbitrary integers as input,
we determine if P outputs the sum of these numbers.
Finally, given a graph with N vertices, determine if it has a clique of size at least k.
Check all that you think are decidable.